- Find the area of a
square with side (6x-5y).
Let me draw our square
and all of the sides
of a square are going
to have the same length,
and they're telling us that the length
for each of the sides which is the same
for all of them is (6x-5y).
So the height would be 6x-5y,
and so would the width, 6x-5y,
and if we wanted to find
the area of the square
we just have to multiply
the width times the height.
So the area for this square
is just going to be the width,
which is (6x-5y) times the height,
times the height which is also (6x-5y),
so we just have to multiply
these two binomials.
To do this, you could either do FOIL
if you like memorizing things
or you could just remember
this is just applying
the distributive property twice.
So what we could do is
distribute this entire magenta,
(6x-5y), distribute it over each
of these terms, in the yellow (6x-5y).
If we do that, we will get
this 6x times this entire (6x-5y),
so (6x-5y), and then we have -5y,
- 5y times once again,
the entire magenta, (6x-5y).
And what does this give us?
So we have, we have 6x times 6x,
so when I distributed just this,
I'm now doing the distributive
property for the second time,
6x times 6x is 36x squared,
and then when I take 6x times -5y,
I get 6 times -5 is -30,
and then I have an x times y, -30xy.
And then I want to take,
I'm trying to introduce many colors here,
so I have this -5y times
this 6x right over here
so -5 times 6 is -30.
- 30 and I have a y and
an x or an x and a y,
and then finally I have my
last distribution to do,
let me do that maybe in white,
I have -5y times another -5y,
so the negative times a
negative is a positive
so it is positive, 5 times 5 is 25,
y times y is y squared.
And then we are almost done.
Right over here, we could say,
we can just add these two terms
in the middle right over here,
- 30xy-30xy is going to be -60xy.
So you get 36x squared -60xy +25y squared.
Now, there is a faster way
to do this if you recognize.
If you recognize that if
I'm squaring a binomial,
which is essentially
what we're doing here,
this is the exact same thing
as 6x-5y squared.
So you might recognize a pattern.
If I have (a+b) squared,
this is the same thing
as (a+b) times (a+b)
and if you were to multiply it out
this exact same way we just did it here,
the pattern here is it's a
times a which is a squared,
plus a times b, +ab, plus b times a,
which is also +ab, we
just switched the order,
plus b squared, +b
squared so this is equal
to a squared +2ab +b squared.
This is kind of the fast way to look,
if you're squaring any binomial,
it will be a+b squared,
it will be a squared +2ab + b squared.
And if you knew this ahead of time,
then you could have just applied that
to this squaring of the
binomial right up here
so let's do it that way as well.
So if we 6x, (6x-5y) squared,
we could just say well, this
is going to be a squared.
It's going to be a squared in which
in this case is 6x squared +2ab,
so that's +2 times a which is (6x)
times b which is (-5y),
- 5y +b squared,
which is +(-5y), everything is squared.
And then this will simplify too,
6x squared is 36x squared plus,
actually it's going to be a negative here
because it's going to be 2 times 6 is 12
times -5 is -60, we have x and a y,
x and a y, and the -5y squared
is +25y squared.
So hopefully you saw
multiple ways to do this,
if you saw this pattern immediately,
and if you knew this pattern immediately,
you could just cut to the
chase and go straight here,
you wouldn't have to do
distributive property twice,
although, this will never be wrong.